Nights ago,
my girlfriend and I had a couple drinks
and convinced ourselves that we needed
to go down the street to bonds for
snacks.
We ended up with a sort of weird
grouping of six items,
toasted sesame water crackers,
some smoked mozzarella cheese chick pea
chips,
it dozen eggs because you always need
eggs.
This sweet young coconut,
because I saw it near the cash register
and scallions because honey,
why don't we get scallions again?
I have no idea.
Well,
apparently nobody knows why.
We got the scallions.
Anyway,
we enjoyed the snacks.
They were all really good,
but then I happened to look at the check
and I realized that I had accidentally
paid for 17 federal programs.
Not exactly,
but let me explain.
This year,
the federal budget requests for the
corporation for public broadcasting.
The organization that runs pbs,
NPR and over 1400 locally owned public
radio and television stations is
$445,000,000
using the latest census information that
comes out to a dollar and thirty seven
cents per American per year or about the
cost of 12 and a half toasted sesame
water crackers.
The National Endowment for the arts,
once a budget of only $150 million to
help fund our exhibitions and our
education across the country to help
America imagine itself artistically.
Each of us has to pay just this much
smoked mozzarella cheese per year.
You might be wondering why I'm bringing
all this up.
It's because in the next few weeks,
you're likely to see the trump
administration proposed dramatic budget
cuts to the federal government that will
seek to prioritize the corporation for
public broadcasting and eliminate the
national endowment of the arts
completely as well as 15 other programs.
Thanks to some good work from Taylor
temper over at Time magazine.
We know that taken together,
these 17 programs will cost every
American $22 and thirty six cents per
year.
The exact cost of my late night snack
run.
Here's what they'll each costs you
individually and what they do.
Cue The montage music.
The National Endowment for the
humanities helps fund museums,
colleges,
libraries,
and things like Ken Burns.
Awesome civil war documentary.
It'll cost you the price of just one egg
in the minority business development
agency promotes the growth of businesses
owned and operated by minority
entrepreneurs.
It costs everyone just eleven cents or
this many chopped scallions.
You can fund the Economic Development
Administration and organization that
supplies regional and local businesses
with the infrastructure they need to
compete in the global market for 20
percent of the water in this coconut for
the cost of six water crackers with
cheese,
you can support the international trade
administration,
which helps enforce trade law for US
companies for 20 percent of one bag of
chick pea chips.
You'll fund the manufacturing extension
partnership,
which is dedicated to small and medium
sized manufacturers.
For 17 percent more chicken chips.
You'll fund the office of violence
against women,
which oversees programs across the
country that reduce domestic violence
and sexual assault.
The Legal Services Corporation helps
poor Americans afford legal services.
That'll cost you just three eggs,
fried plus some scallions.
The civil rights division of the Justice
Department fights discrimination and
protects voting rights.
That'll cost you just a couple shots of
coconut water,
plus some scallions to fund the UN
intergovernmental panel on climate
change,
which compiles the latest scientific
data on global warming.
You have to throw in just this much of a
chick pea chip you office of
electricity,
deliverability and energy reliability
invests in making our energy grid more
stable and secure.
It costs all the scallions.
The scallions are really cheap,
and finally the office of energy
efficiency and renewable energy aids
efforts to transition America to a clean
energy economy.
It's the most expensive of the bunch you
get.
It only cost the price of one box of
water crackers and one bag of chips.
The blueprint for these cuts comes from
a paper put out by the Heritage
Foundation,
a conservative think tank that has long
argued for eliminating federal programs
as a way to reduce our
$20,000,000,000,000
national debt.
But the problem is that altogether these
programs are asking for only seven point
$3,000,000,000,
which is one percent of the non defense
discretionary spending that our
government does.
Fully half of discretionary spending
goes to the military.
Something that the trump administration
is not likely to slash all that much,
and in total,
all discretionary spending makes up only
31 percent of the federal budget.
The rest goes to social security.
Medicare,
Medicaid entitlements that trump has
also vowed not to touch.
In other words,
privatizing or eliminating b 17 programs
is really only a symbolic gesture that
won't do much of anything.
The good news is that this is a fight
that should be pretty easy to win.
If you're willing to spend drunkenly or
not.
Twenty $2 and thirty six cents on these
17 programs,
call your congressman and say so,
and if they want to know why you think
privatizing pbs or killing the National
Endowment of the arts is a bunch of
bullshit,
feel free to send them this video.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
Nerdwriter tee shirts still available at
[inaudible] dot com.
Send me a picture if you've got one.
Anyway,
thanks to crunchy roll for sponsoring
this episode.
If you don't know,
crunchy roll is like the Netflix of
animated.
It's really cool.
It's got thousands of titles,
all hd,
and if something errors in Japan,
it's going to be on crunchy roll an hour
later so you can see the latest stuff,
anime stuff coming out of Japan on
crunchy roll.
I want to recommend cowboy bebop,
which is,
in my opinion,
a work of art and if you sign up at
[inaudible] dot com slash nerd writer,
you can get a free 30 day trial which
would allow you to watch that show and I
think that you would really like it.
Um,
anyway,
I'll see you guys next Wednesday and
thanks again for watching.